Fox Sports college football analyst also
from si.com Bruce Feldman joining us
here Bruce where are you calling in from
where are you I'm holding LA but I was
spent a week at the College Conference
meetings in Arizona and Scottsdale
pretty much everybody other than the SEC
and the ACC you know head coaches ADEs
football basketball they're all in there
is on all week so it's a UH it's kind of
a good good set up just get face time
and just kind of kind of beat us with
all okay so first question is what what
is what are we meeting to discuss there
Condoleezza Rice I mean what else what
are they bringing up at this spot Bruce
you know a lot of it is really just
about how the sport is run at that point
you know everything for you know my
bosses at Fox and a lot of folks at ESPN
higher up are there because they talk
about little you know issues maybe that
they think they can do better you know
in terms of you know working on the
relationships and there's other things
where coaches want to talk about
everything from the transfer policies or
you know different things that they
think will come down the pipeline but
it's really a lot of like cocktail party
scene I don't know where they kind of
reconnect from you know one senior all
all base of the whole sport gets
together there well there can't be
anything significant being discussed on
changes or in college football if the
SEC is not there Bruce you would think I
know it's funny one topic that comes up
a lot is you know how can the FCC still
have for non-conference games and
usually a couple of cupcakes in there
when pretty much everybody else that's
three which is obviously you know a
little more challenging then going off
the board and but that's the nature of
college sports right now it's where it's
not uniform it's very different from
what you see in the pro sports and you
know yes you see keeps one in titles so
they you know it's gonna come becomes
this cycle you know or kid you get teams
that end up in the top 25 maybe because
they're I want you know the records are
more padded but there's there's stuff
like something to that okay and I saw
you you put out a column recently and
that the
the thing that concerns a band Meyer the
most for those that did not read your
column what was that about Bruce yeah
you know so I didn't set out to do this
story this way but I after talking to a
lot of players around the program you
know we talked about basically he has
this program called real life Wednesdays
and it's something he's been doing for a
while but it's really evolved and quite
honestly he's evolved in the last few
years and so what you get is a lot of
kids had said you know these issues that
are that are much bigger than just hey
we're gonna win some some football games
becomes to whether it's depression or
things like anxiety they're there
now realize that there's seen enough
horror stories that have come out and
it's like hey are we doing enough to
address these issues with our players
and so you know I went back I think I
had visited Ohio State maybe five years
ago and a reminder strength coach who
the same guy who was with him at Florida
had told me you know exactly Bourbon
comes back from a vacation or wherever
you know he's got an armful all these
ideas how to make you know things they
can do that maybe will make them better
players and when I brought that up to
urban you know the other day the big
thing was yeah it used to be basically
like 80/20 was all football and and you
know the 20% was the other stuff now
it's all about all the other stuff and
it's a really fraction of it split is
the football part and that's what he's
consumed by and so he's hard to do in
close to he'll say well when he went
home or when he went on a recruiting
trip this winter you know he gets
overwhelmed by hearing about things like
the opioid crisis that's you know Rach
the the area where he's from and so I
think there becomes part of him where
what's unique I think about urban
services from being around a lot of
different other programs you know that
we go in to cover games on he's got
cable news on all the time when you're
in his office and you know that can
certainly be mind-numbing
and the players you talk to were like oh
you know what he had certain views that
may be in line with some of those people
he sees on
b-but then he knows us and trust us in
the others roids else and when we bring
these experiences to him he's become
very open and they think it's actually
changed him and certainly changed his
perspective and that's what's so
different because you see a story like
the tragic story like Tyler go and see
the quarterback at Washington State
we've taken his own life this winter
that that was a big deal not just around
you know that community that was a huge
deal all around college sports and and
Urban Meyer's trying to figure out what
can we do to to address these it's a
great piece on si.com check it out let's
be fair and balanced here everything
that I heard about Shay Patterson
getting that waiver from Ole Miss and
playing at Michigan game changer is the
words that I've heard and it's a crucial
season obviously for Jim Harbaugh and
Michigan football coming off for last
year's five lost disappointment is that
is that an accurate description of Shay
Patterson being allowed to play football
this this fall for the Wolverines I
think it is just because they were so
underwhelming at that position last you
know some of it had to do with you know
new receivers and you know you lost not
just that you know it's two really good
receivers a little big targets but a
really good tight end and so they had to
change that but I also think you take
this kid this kid has a terrific on the
ball jumps out of his hand his release
is probably as good as their there will
be in college football you know there's
some there's definitely some stuff he
needs to work on the arm is is great he
needs work on a different
decision-making you know some of the
intangible things are still a work in
progress with him so you know I don't
want folks to jump in goal it's a former
five-star guy and he should be the first
pick in the draft because there are
certainly some things that he's got that
are better of that Hill but there's some
other things that are definitely you
know decision making was a big piece of
it you know I think accuracy is good I
think they you know so there's a lot of
refinement there but I think he is much
more talented and then what they had
there for quite some time and I would
say the most talented quarterback Jim
Harbaugh's had in college football we
said today that Stanford would that you
are so
it all comes down to it now that we're
post raft Bruce and so many quarterbacks
went off the board in the NFL Draft
which team do you think in college
football's gonna have the smoothest
transition to a new quarterback this
fall of those guys who lost quarterback
you know lost high you know
because Oklahoma State's going from a
guy in Mason we're off the plate of time
with lost some early receivers to
probably a guy who's a grad transfer
from Hawaii you know Oklahoma will go
from one dynamic you know undersized
shorter quarterback in Baker Mayfield to
Cuyler Murray he's even shorter and
faster
I think USC has the most interesting
transition because they they will go
from Sam d'Arnaud who was terrific in
his you know year and a half almost two
years of starter to a guy who I think
will win the job he's a true freshman
quarterback who comes from a same high
school as Matt Matt Leinart matt barkley
modern-day it's a powerhouse in Orange
County this kids really smart really
talented JT Daniels
I think he's not the guy because the
other quarterbacks they had really
really struggled you know when you watch
them in the spring and I think there's a
lot of pressure on a kid who has not you
know it's not even enrolled yet and he's
graduating I think next you know later
this month but you know us he should be
the favorite in it in the south in the
pack south but I just think that the bar
for this kid is really really high he
graduated a year early from high school
he's still 18 years old so he's not like
he's really younger than most kids but
he should he was expected to be a senior
in high school and now he's jumped into
the pac-12 football and like I said the
expectations really high on and is it
possible that that Chip Kelly's first
quarterback at UCLA with Rosen now in
Arizona is Wilton spate formerly of
Michigan is that yeah it's entirely
possible he's gradually you know he had
some success in 2016 you know like I
said when those receivers were actually
it's much better last year struggled we
had the Purdue game where he got hurt
and I was pretty much it for him you
know I think he's a there's there's some
positives when he's played a lot if it's
not him I think it'll be another kid
who's not there yet a freshman Dorian
Thompson Robinson from Las Vegas
who
is you know really athletic kid good
runner dual track guy kind of what you
think of when you expect a Chip Kelly
quarterback which quite honestly will
the state does not fit that profile but
I would put out this caveat I've seen
UCLA and spring a few times they do not
have a lot to work with right now I
would expect to see a ton of true
freshmen playing a lot for Chip Kelly
and don't be surprised and this team
struggles to make a bowl game because
the cupboard is pretty bare I wouldn't
be shocked if they were only favored in
two games a season so somebody who's
been around Bruce Feldman here on the
Rich Eisen show former you well you once
an author always an author the the book
that came out in 2014 the QB the making
of modern quarterbacks you've been
around the elite 11 program for quite
some time obviously covering a college
football were you surprised at the
evaluation that that spit out Baker
Mayfield as the number one overall pick
in the NFL Draft Bruce a little
surprised not shocked because I thought
all five quarterbacks you know who are
in the mix had some level of issues to
be concerned about Baker doesn't have
ideal Heidi's I mean I was surprised you
and measured as tall as six and a half
you know I I've interviewed him after
our games you know I've spent a bunch of
time I'm not six feet nine have not I
thought Baker and I are almost the exact
same height but that's you know look
that can be a moot point as you see with
Drew Brees Russell Wilson I think the
thing is that's different of those guys
you know they didn't have any any
baggage now I mean what he was arrested
for it wasn't it was not you know it's
never good to be arrested but it wasn't
like it was not like he had the issues
Johnny Manziel had coming out of out of
out of Texas A&M which were which were
big substance issues these were these
were different for him it's just kind of
being a knucklehead at times but when
you watch Baker the thing that allows
you as a just as if somebody covered
college was the only was the only the
best player in the field everything was
the focal point with him you know I I
think Baker feels not the starter I know
you last year not only they not make the
playoff I'm not sure if they win more
than eight games you know their defense
was decent it wasn't that good wasn't
like they had
you know great great skill talented
pretty good skill talent but even go
back to your earlier DD West Brooklyn's
the Biletnikoff Award
yeah he's fast but it's not like DD
Westbrook is Larry Fitzgerald I mean I
think a lot of that was Lincoln Reilly's
a great play caller and I think a lot of
it is Baker Mayfield is a great
triggerman and last one for you Bruce
out of all the evaluation stories that
you have heard through your years of
doing this where does the alonzo
highsmith finding the volleyball coach
of the women's volleyball team of UCLA
in an airport asking him about Josh
Rosen then getting the answer you need
to ask his girlfriend and then reading a
red flag just into that alone Bruce
where does that rank for you I think it
fits into the category that's not my
kind of guy I look at it when I see it
and I'll find something that probably
you know kind of substantiates my my
initial you know glance at it and I
think there's a lot of there's a lot of
that that goes on as for all the time
that I spend there's a lot of it that
goes on you know not just in NFL Draft
ones but also in college recruiting
where you just look at somebody like in
I don't know if that fits what I'm
looking for and I would use this example
Luke Kuechly is a phenomenal linebacker
I remember talking of a dukkha system
and they said why I asked why do you
think more schools didn't want him in
there they would see him walking around
school wear glasses on they look like a
nerd they're like that can't possibly be
you know a linebacker you know that's
you know and is that why Notre Dame pass
some it took somebody else from that you
know from that same area who knows but
it's just like I think a lot of that is
is really on personas as much as
anything and so you know look maybe
maybe the people who were gun shy on
joshloz and will be proven right you
know because it's like it's a 50/50 deal
with all this and I you know I don't
think anybody can be can be totally
convinced yeah this guy's you know the
the Quintin Nelson's and safe on
Barclays and make it Fitzpatrick's there
they are the exception rather than the
rule in this process Bruce great chat as
always we'll chat soon okay my pleasure
you talk to you rich hey you gotta add
Bruce Feldman CFP the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on